one out of three hundred percent chance
or something along those lines can
either that's gonna have to understand
that more I mean Santa whoa whoa whoa
whoa Wow whoa whoa whoa whoa there tear
or wasteland one
why is everything trapped in ice what
the hell what the hell was that a bear
good ball throw oh I'm finally God and
no stars guy our stars
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa no one got that
off
no one blast what without his permission
first without permission
Tommy was whoa whoa whoa you shouldn't
be watching this everyone I don't know
why I'm covering my camera and not
everyone else hey I'm just gonna slam
dunk whoa whoa whoa whoa I didn't even
get a chance you know there's a piece of
glass on my ass see how long you can how
long I can what how long I can totally
escape this by doing some sick moves oh
come on that was lame go tractor go
impossible 99.9% impossible Yeah right
so bro these spike fall slam dunk time
okay got it gonna nail it
pop [ __ ] nutters boom
what escaped of the circle how am I
going to be epic tumble no cradle to fat
toes it's gonna start here and roll a
bit don't wait say let's go through
[Music]
impossible nothing is impossible
hold on longest five what happens if I
don't don't do anything
what happens if I just watch them go by
nothing go go go go go go go yeah yeah
what now we're now buddy we're now
friend come on ow
[Applause]
Oh fro ha don't don't get it into death
anything but the death just know I see
that giant jet there just no death no
I'm done protect me no no first catch me
Mom swore throw dr hello hello you good
people you are boos is bad for you
watermelon makes you fat
just like Santa oh no no no thought that
was gonna get me dinya yeah don't move
Forney I'll be the judge of that up I'm
taking you with me [ __ ] suck on that
how do you like me now oh don't move
I'll fetch your mother yeah yeah
BMX park yeah I'll have fun sweet moves
bro no need arms arms are bad front flip
no not listening to you
candy I'll grind I'm here bloody mess
but I'm still going for it you all right
there son you don't look so good with
all your limbs in time let's fix that
okay alright I'm trying to kill you son
I really am but it's not working I'm a
failure as a father
whoa whoa kitties what do you think
you're doing there
we're on a rope swing which means that
we need to move and it's repeatedly
proper fastened but we seem to be
sucking okay could eat I'm gonna go for
help you just can retain each other
without involve me
oh my god it's late return home before
your wife gets suspicious come home a
fighter choo oh hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa football I had up three sons huh
Fahd know right ways to die wait for
screen.i way for no screams eek a
flotation two pieces white hands these
aren't these aren't working
hup-hup-hup-hup-hup
yeah so hilariously awesome hell yeah oh
dear sward throw I'll get to you in a
second pop we're all sorry about the 50
throw everybody oh my god holy crap oh
sorry I'm sorry everybody
oh my god one more try one more try
haha oh man I cannot throw these what
what what no sir no it's not Santa got
it dumped no I'm stuck my arms
ah miss that fine signals
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha
Pfc gladiator to demo excuse me sir have
you seen a gladiator around here baby
killer
excuse me lady lady hey this looks like
a sword throw perfect take that devil
son kid toughness to pin the foe my god
Spira
take that baby yeah I killed everyone
no there's one more mom mom I've got so
much built-up anger towards you I'm
gonna getcha I think I just killed
Tobuscus sorry Toby I killed myself I
deserved it sorry give a sir have you
been dead lately suck on that [ __ ] ow
ow oh oh my god
shower of blood huh hi I got it okay ha
okay well go in go in go in where to go
where to go where to go where'd it go
where'd it go oh wait hang on I'm not
gonna stop this I need to find this
gladiator get me all right get out of
the way baby lady lady lady all right
I'm just gonna reason with you don't
stab me with anything so I'm gonna get
real close to you baby and anyone ever
told you how good you look
oh yes sorry son you can't see this get
on my unicorn horn and let's go Oh
Oh
WWE street fight he's down there well
I'm gonna coward you know gonna get him
body slam slam ow he didn't get a
scratch on him but I got mangled rope
swing swing swing oh not again I
couldn't grab on I know uh uh what were
you doing there uh huh why'd you run
away uh-huh uh-huh rainbow glass tears
ow ow ow
why why why why is this a thing
why is this a thing wearily glass here
why is this here
why oh no I'm not falling for that one
that's quite obviously a trap I'm just
gonna kill myself here apparently yep
damn we're dead where'd my hat go
Epic's ward throw is it is it really
alright we're gonna actually win this
one okay wow wow wow whoa whoa whoa
thanks for taking my place there kitty
twenty sward throw once again I will be
the judge of what is funny and what is
not throw JB here
Darla her sake sake kill the person Bob
no no no wow pick sward throw oh come on
since it weighs like ten thousand pounds
take that that's what you get for
drinking drink is bad for you moon Kay
[Music]
haha no no no ha ha help okay
guy in the help yeah come on give me the
ball yep not really what I wanted but
okay oh no no this one is called harpoon
gunshots fall do schmack novels
McGillicuddy you know my cookies what
will I do without her
called the boost whoa whoa whoa what
just whatever
hold on a second everybody as Earth
tumbling in Santa's head cuz this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you like what your son you
want to see more why not subscribe to my
channel wanna help the channel grow
leave a like add in to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]